is it true you shaved the mustache
earlier this year because i don't know
if i've seen you without the mustache
other than this time
that's the one day i didn't have a
mustache um
that's so good well i started growing it
in the summer between the 11th and the
12th grade
and so i've been with my wife for 36
years and she had never seen me without
it because i've
because i've always i never had a break
where i wasn't doing
either a concert or a tv show and then
when they
you know when they started canceling
shows i thought
all right i got time to shave it off and
i didn't even say anything i just went
in the bathroom and shaved it off and i
walked out
and she looked at me and said oh wow
grow it back
and so i literally shaved my lip
one time as an adult and because i
didn't know how long it took to grow it
back but it takes
between two and three weeks so i guess
depending on the person you're a chia
pet that's awesome
um well but here was the funny thing
like
so i posted it on instagram and there
were some people that were like oh wow
you look younger
but kelly i swear 80 of them were like
no
no no you you are supposed to have a
mustache
grow it back you know so sell it for me
you have to have a mustache he has to
have a mustache
it's just what we're used to um but sam
elliott sam elliott does not look right
without
elliott best cowboy ever yes he has to
have one too
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going